SENATORS, THEY ARE LOOKING FOR A
WAY OUT.
WE’LL EXPLAIN ALL OF THIS
TONIGHT BUT NOW WE TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO WHAT WE ARE CALLING
WHAT IS THE BIG LIBERAL
EXTREMIST SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY LIES.
THIS IS A SHORT LIST TONIGHT.
FIRST, THERE IS A COMPLETELY
FALSE PERCEPTION.
DEMOCRATS, THE ACTUALLY VALUE
FREEDOM.
NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER FROM
THE TRUTH.
NOW, WHILE THE CLASSIC
DEFINITION OF LIBERALISM IS A
WILLINGNESS TO RESPECT NEW IDEAS
AND THEY SUPPORT FREEDOM OF
SPEECH.
THEY ARE PRO-CHOICE, FREEDOM OF
INSPECTION.
WHILE, TEDDY’S RADICAL
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS ANYTHING BUT
THEY DON’T WANT ANY FREEDOM OF
SPEECH.
THEY WANT TO COMPLETELY SILENCE,
CANCEL ALL OPPOSITION VOICES,
STIFLE SPEECH THAT THEY DISAGREE
WITH, AND FURTHERMORE CANCEL
ANYONE THAT DARES OFFEND THEM.
NATIONALLY, THEY APPLAUD THE
EFFORTS OF BIG TECH TO CENSOR
CONSERVATIVES.
NOT ONE PROMINENT DEMOCRAT HAS
SPOKEN OUT AGAINST THIS
PRACTICE, NOT ONE.
DEMOCRATS, LEFTISTS, THEY ARE
ALSO LEADING THE CALLS AND THEY
HAVE FOR YEARS AGAINST A FEW OF
US HERE ON THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
THEY WOULD LIKE US ALL CANCELED
AND BOYCOTTED AND SHUT DOWN ON
CONSERVATIVE TALK RADIO.
ME, RUSH LIMBAUGH, THE GREAT
ONE.
WE NEED TO BE RIPPED OFF THE
AIRWAYS.
AND THAT’S NOT ALL.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
ALREADY LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
PREVENT ANY TOUGH QUESTIONS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS.
I’M NOT MAKING THIS UP.
YOU HAVE THE PRESS SECRETARY
TELLING POLITICO WE EXPECT
REPORTERS COVERING THE
WHITE HOUSE TO OPERATE IN GOOD
FAITH AND ORGANIZATIONS OR
INDIVIDUALS IN CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, LIKE CNN, ABC,
PROPAGANDA, "WASHINGTON POST,"
THOSE THAT LIE AND SPREAD
DISINFORMATION WILL NOT BE
TOLERATED.
THEY WILL ALL BE THROWN OUT
TOMORROW AND WE WILL WORK WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
ASSOCIATION TO DECIDE HOW TO
HANDLE THOSE INSTANCES MOVING
FORWARD.
AND WHO MAKES ALL OF THESE
DECISIONS?
THAT WOULD BE THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT ARE PERFECTLY OKAY WITH NOT
REPORTING ON THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP STORY AND
"THE NEW YORK POST," YOU KNOW,
THE ONE THAT WAS TRUE.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF YOU REPORT
SOMETHING THEY DON’T LIKE OR YOU
DON’T BUY INTO THEIR LIVES,
THEIR HOAXES, THERE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, THEY WILL JUST CANCEL
YOU, SILENCE YOU, SHUT YOU DOWN,
AND APPARENTLY KICK YOU OUT AND
THEY WILL WORK WITH THEIR ALLIES
AND THE MEDIA MOB AND THEIR
ALLIES IN BIG TECH.
AND THEY WILL WALK YOU OUT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE AND COMPLETELY
CANCEL YOU.
AND THE DEMOCRATS PERFECT
UTOPIA, THERE IS NO DIFFERENCE.
THERE ARE NO DISAGREEMENTS, NO
ALTERNATIVE OPINIONS WHATSOEVER.
THEIR TOURISTIC TWISTED PSYCHOTI
THE WORLD, THEY HOLD THE
MONOPOLY ON TRUTH.
AND AS WE HAVE LONG DISCUSSED ON
THIS PROGRAM.
THEY ALSO BELIEVE AND THEY WILL
TELL YOU THAT THEY HAVE A
MONOPOLY ON COMPASSION, WHICH
BRINGS US TO ANOTHER BIG RADICAL
LEFTIST SADIST DEMOCRATIC LIE.
THAT IS A LIE AND THIS IS
DEFINITELY NOT THE PARTY THAT
HAS A MONOPOLY ON COMPASSION
THAT IS LOOKING OUT FOR
HARDWORKING MEN AND WOMEN IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THE PERSON THAT SET RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT,
AFRICAN-AMERICAN ON EMPLOYMENT,
THOSE RECORDS WERE SHATTERED BY
THAT WOULD BE PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
EXILE.
RADICAL SOCIALISTS BASED, IN
LESS THAN ONE WEEK IN OFFICE,
THE WEEK, THE FRAIL JOE BIDEN
HAS NOW BEEN PUTTING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF OUR FOLLOW
HARDWORKING AMERICANS,
LAW-ABIDING TAXPAYING CITIZENS
OUT OF WORK.
THEIR WORK HAS BEEN CANCELED ALL
IN THE NAME OF THIS RADICAL NEW
GREEN DEAL SOCIALIST
REDISTRIBUTION MODEL THAT THEY
NOW ENDORSE.
KEEP IN MIND, WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC BECAUSE OF
A LOT OF DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS
AND MAYORS EMMA WE HAVE HAD
DRACONIAN SHUTDOWN MEASURES AND
AN UNEMPLOYMENT AND THE JOBS
THAT ARE FAILING, WELL,
EXTREMELY HIGH.
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
OUT OF WORK THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN AND JOE ADDING TO
MISERY HAS BASICALLY ANNOUNCED
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE COMPETITION
FOR THE JOBS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
BY GIVING AMNESTY TO 11 MILLION
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
BY THE STROKE OF A PEN, TWICE
THIS WEEK JOE HAS DECIDED TO
STOP CONSTRUCTION OF THE BORDER
WALL, CANCEL THE PIPELINE
CAUSING YES, THOUSANDS MORE TO
BE LAID OFF.
THEY ALREADY GOT THEIR PINK
SLIPS.
WE HAVE INTERVIEWED THEM.
AND FURTHER RESTRICTIONS ON
AMERICAN FRACKING, NATURAL GRASS
GRASS, PULLING BACK ON HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN JOBS.
KEEP IN MIND, THESE ARE HIGH
PAYING JOBS WITH GREAT BENEFITS.
MOST OF THEM ARE UNION JOBS.
THEY FIT A VERY SPECIFIC SKILL
SET.
A LOT OF THEM ARE MAKING SIX
FIGURES.
THEY ARE JOBLESS.
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN, HIS
CLIMATE PLAN IS ABOUT JOBS.
IT’S NOT LIKE YOU SAY WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE THIS JOB AND GIVE
YOU THIS JOB.
THAT NEVER OCCURRED.
THEY LOST THEIR CURRENT JOB WITH
NO HOPE OR REALITY OF GETTING A
JOB THAT IS GOING TO PAY THEM
100 GRAND A YEAR.
>> TODAY IS CLIMATE DAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WHICH MEANS THAT
TODAY IS A JOB STAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WHEN I THINK OF CLIMATE CHANGE,
I THINK ABOUT JOBS.
A KEY PLANK OF OUR BILLS BETTER
RECOVERY PLAN IS BUILDING A
MODERN RESILIENT AND CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE THAT WILL CREATE
MILLIONS OF GOOD PAYING UNION
JOBS, NOT SEVEN, EIGHT, TEN, $12
AN HOUR BUT A PREVAILING WAGE
AND BENEFITS.
>> Sean: THE GUYS IN THE
ENERGY SECTOR ARE GETTING PAID
ON AVERAGE 100 GRAND A YEAR.
YOU JUST LAID THEM OFF, JOE.
ARE YOU GOING TO PAY THEIR
MORTGAGE?
ARE YOU GOING TO PAY THEIR RENT?
YOU JUST DESTROYED THEIR
CAREERS, THEIR DREAMS, THEIR
LIVELIHOODS.
MILLIONS OF JOBS ARE GOING TO BE
CREATED, GOOD JOBS.
HOW DO YOU PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
NEXT WEEK?
OR PAY THEIR CAR PAYMENT NEXT
WEEK?
THE COMPETITION RIGHT NOW FOR
JOBS HAS NEVER BEEN GREATER AND
BECAUSE OF AMNESTY AND BECAUSE
OF DRACONIAN SHUTDOWNS, IT’S
GOING TO DRIVE DOWN WAGES.
YOU ARE TAKING AWAY JOBS AND
PROMISING BIG GOVERNMENT.
THE COLDHEARTED COMMENTS OF
BIDEN’S CABINETS ARE EQUALLY
INSANE.
YOU’VE GOT HIS SPECIAL ENVOY.
THESE AMERICANS NEED TO FIND
WORK ELSEWHERE.
EASY FOR HIM TO SAY.
HE’S A MULTI-MULTIMILLIONAIRE IN
HIS OWN PRIVATE JET.
I DON’T REMEMBER HIM EVER
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST THE
KENNEDYS OF NANTUCKET WHEN THEY
WERE GOING TO BUILD WINDMILLS
THERE.
IT WOULD HAVE OBSTRUCTED THE
KENNEDY VIEW.
HE NEVER CRITICIZED THAT AND
MANY OF THESE WORKERS, ADD I TO
I SAID HAVE SIX FIGURES.
HEY JOHN KERRY, WHERE DO THEY GO
FOR WORK ON MONDAY?
CAN THEY GO TO TAKE A JET TO GO
INTERVIEW?
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS EXPRESSED IN
EVERY COMMENT HE HAS MADE ABOUT
THE CLIMATE, THE NEED TO GROW
THE NEW JOBS THAT PAY BETTER,
THAT ARE CLEANER.
WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN WANTS TO DO
IS MAKE SURE THOSE FOLKS HAVE
BETTER CHOICES, THAT THEY CAN BE
THE PEOPLE TO GO TO WORK TO MAKE
THE SOLAR PANELS.
THEY WERE MAKING THEM HERE AT
HOME.
THAT IS GOING TO BE A PARTICULAR
FOCUS OF THE BUILD BACK BETTER
AGENDA.
>> Sean: NEXT WEEK THEY’VE GOT
NO JOB TO GO TO, JOHN.
I KNOW YOU MARRIED INTO A LOT OF
MONEY.
I KNOW YOU FLY AROUND THE WORLD
LEAVING YOUR BIG FAT CARBON
FOOTPRINT PRETTY MUCH EVERYWHERE
YOU GO.
BY THE WAY, JOHN KERRY, MAY BE A
NEED TO SCRAP YOUR PRIVATE JET.
I THINK IT’S TIME TO SELL THE
PLANE.
THAT MAKES YOU A LYING
HYPOCRITE.
AND HE IS STANDING THERE WITH
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE AS
CALLOUSLY AS CLIMATE ENVOY
ARGUING THAT AMERICANS WILL NOT
BE WORKING NEXT WEEK.
THEY SHOULD LOSE THEIR JOB
BECAUSE OF HIS RADICAL GLOBALLY
DOMINANT GLOBAL WARMING
GREEN NEW DEAL SOCIALIST AGENDA
AS HE USES A PRIVATE JET AS A LO
THE CABINET MEMBERS OF
JOE BIDEN, ARE THEY GOING TO
GIVE UP THE GOVERNMENT JETS THAT
PAID FOR, THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER?
THEY’VE GOT FLEETS OF THEM.
ARE THEY GOING TO AGREE TO GIVE
THEM UP?
I DOUBT IT.
HE ISN’T THE ONLY BIDEN OFFICIAL
WITH A CAVALIER ATTITUDE EITHER.
BY THE WAY, ALL AGAINST WORKING
AMERICANS.
THEY ARE NOW DEVASTATED BY YES,
THE PINK SLIPS THAT THEY GOT AND
NO JOB TO GO TO.
HIGH PAYING CAREER JOBS IN THE
ENERGY INDUSTRY.
THEY DON’T HAVE A JOB ON MONDAY.
WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO GO
MONDAY?
WHO’S GOING TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE?
WAS GOING TO PAY THEIR RENT,
THEIR MORTGAGE?
ANYWAY, TAKE A LOOK AT OTHER
CALLOUSNESS?
>> OVER THERE HOUSE WORKERS,
SOMEBODY ELSE WILL GET A JOB?
>> THEY MIGHT BE DIFFERENT ONE.
>> Sean: YOU JUST TOOK THEIR
JOB AND YOU DIDN’T GIVE THEM
ANOTHER JOB.
THEY DON’T EXACTLY HAVE THE
WEALTH OF EXPERIENCE OR
KNOWLEDGE.
AND PETE, YOU JUST GOT A NEW
JOB.
THEY HAD GOOD PAYING UNION JOBS.
YOU PUT THE INSANE SOCIALIST
GREEN NEW DEAL AHEAD OF EVERYONE
OF THESE HARDWORKING AMERICAN
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
PETE’S COLLEAGUE, JENNIFER WAS
AT LEAST A BIT MORE HONEST BY
SAYING AND STATING THAT OF
COURSE JOBS ARE GOING TO BE
SACRIFICED, BUT THE TOMEI BY THE
DEMOCRAT’S RADICAL GREEN NEW DEA
AGENDA.
>> I’M JUST CURIOUS HOW THE
LONG-TERM BAND CONSISTENT WITH
THE PRESENT’S GOAL OF PUTTING
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AND HELPING
OUR ECONOMIES GROW, HOW IS THAT
ALL CONSISTENT?
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT’S PLAN
OF BUILDING THAT BETTER, WHICH
WOULD CREATE MORE JOBS IN
ENERGY, CLEAN ENERGY THAN THE
JOBS THAT MIGHT BE SACRIFICED.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS.
WE DON’T WANT TO SEE ANY JOBS
SACRIFICED.
>> Sean: HOW DOES A WELDER AND
A PIPE FITTER, TELL ME, HOW DO
THOSE SKILLS, VERY SPECIFIC
LEARNED OVER DECADES IN SOME
CASES, HOW DO THEY TRANSLATE TO
WINDMILLS?
YOU’VE GOT TO HELP ME OUT HERE.
PERHAPS SHE’S MORE HONEST BUT
JUST AS DUMB IN SUPPORTING THIS
MADNESS AND ADDING INSERT TO
INJURY.
GUESS WHAT, YOU ARE ALSO GOING
TO BE FACING HIGHER TAXES AS
WELL AS HIGHER ENERGY TASKS.
IN THE JOE BIDEN GENIUS ON TOP
OF THE PREDICTABLE RISING PRICES
FOR YOUR HOME, THEY ARE EYEING A
BRAND-NEW GAS TAX.
TAX HIKES ON THE MIDDLE CLASS.
YEAH, PROBABLY GOING TO BE
NECESSARY TO PAY FOR JOE’S NEW
GREEN DEAL SOCIALIST AGENDA.
WINDMILLS, SOLAR PANELS.
HATE TO TELL YOU THAT IT’S NOT
CHEAP.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER SOLYNDRA.
HIGH TAXES ON YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE WHO
TRULY MAKE THIS COUNTRY GREAT
EVERY DAY WHEN HE WAS HIDING IN
HIS BASEMENT BUNKER DURING THE
CAMPAIGN PROTECTION PROGRAM WITH
THE MEDIA MOB AND THE BIG TECH
MOB.
I DON’T RECALL PROMISING TO
RAISE TAXES ON THE MIDDLE CLASS.
MATTER OF FACT IF MY MEMORY
SERVES ME WELL IT WAS QUITE THE
OPPOSITE.
LET’S SEE IF THE VIDEOTAPE
PROVES ME RIGHT.
>> THIS IS ABOUT EVERYBODY
PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE.
>> SO $400,000.
>> THERE IS NO NEED.
>> WILL YOU BE RAISING TAXES ON
SMALL BUSINESSES?
>> YOU HAVE 90% OF THE
BUSINESSES OUT THERE WHO ARE
MOM-AND-POP BUSINESSES.
THEY ARE OUT THERE THAT EMPLOY
LESS THAN 50 PEOPLE.
NOBODY MAKING MORE THAN 500,000
BUCKS SHOULD HAVE THEIR TAXES
RAISE PERIOD.
LET’S GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
>> Sean: OKAY, JUST TOOK AWAY
THEIR JOBS AND JENNIFER, YOU ARE
ON DEFENSE.
GOING TO RAISE TAXES ON THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
BUT I GUESS YOU CONSIDER ANYONE
WHO HAS A JOB STILL MIDDLE-CLASS
MIDDLE-CLASS.
WHAT JOE BIDEN DID WAS LIE
DIRECTLY TO YOUR FACE.
I THOUGHT THE MEDIA MOB DIDN’T
LIKE LYING FROM POLITICIANS.
BY THE WAY, WE TOLD YOU SO.
WE PREDICTED ALL OF THIS.
BY THE WAY, NONE OF THIS WILL
IMPROVE THE CLIMATE.
THE WORLD WILL STILL CONSUME OIL
AND GAS, BUT NOW LESS OF IT WILL
BE SOURCED FROM AMERICA.
INSTEAD, ALL OF THE OIL AND GAS,
THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE WORLD’S
ECONOMY, THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO SHIP IT ON TRAINS.
WE WILL BE EXPORTING OIL TO
COUNTRIES THAT HATE OUR GUTS,
CHINA, A HOSTILE REGIME, RUSSIA,
HOSTILE REGIME.
OTHER COUNTRIES.
VENEZUELA.
WOW.
NO EPA IN THESE COUNTRIES.
THE PARIS CLIMATE RECORDS.
THEY DON’T CHARGE CHINA THE SAME
AS THEY CHARGE US.
CHINA IS CONSIDERED A DEVELOPING
NATION.
WE ARE THE ONLY SUCKERS THAT PAY
THE REAL FREIGHT.
I GUESS WE ARE GOING TO MAKE ALL
OF THOSE HOSTILE REGIMES AGAINST
US RICH AGAIN.
WE’LL MAKE THEM GREAT AGAIN.
AND AMERICA ONCE AGAIN WILL BE
DEPENDENT ON FOREIGN ENERGY
WHICH COMPROMISES OUR SECURITY.
NOT A GOOD IDEA.
POLLUTION WILL PROBABLY GET
WORSE.
WE WILL BE PAYING PRICES ON THE
WAY AND TO SUM IT UP, WE ARE
GOING TO PAY MORE TO PAY HEAT
OUR HOMES, MORE AT THE PUMP.
AND THEY WILL ALL GET RICH AND
THEY WILL BE PROSPERING.
THEY ARE DOING BACK FLIPS
TONIGHT.
TENS AND THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
ARE LOSING HIGH-PAYING CAREER
JOBS.
RUSSIA, CHINA, IRAN, OTHER
MIDDLE EASTERN COUNTRIES DOING
BACKFLIPS AND GOING GETTING
TONIGHT.
HERE’S MY PREDICTION.
MARK MY WORDS, THIS WILL NOT END
WELL.
ON TOP OF THIS, BIDEN HAS
PLANNED TO KEEP DEMOCRATS IN
POWER.
I WARNED YOU ABOUT THIS TOO.
IT’S HAPPENING.
AND THAT INCLUDES, BY THE WAY, A
BILL THAT WOULD GRANT STATEHOOD
TO WASHINGTON, D.C., THEREFORE
ENSURING TWO DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
FROM D.C.
MAYBE PUERTO RICAN STATEHOOD IS
NEXT.
THEY WILL HAVE TWO MORE
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS IN
PERPETUITY.
BIDEN IS NOW STAFFING A
COMMISSION TO ANALYZE
SUPREME COURT REFORM.
OKAY.
I WAS RIGHT AGAIN.
LET ME TRANSLATE THAT FOR YOU.
TALKING ABOUT COURT PACKING,
THEY WANT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
CONTROL THE U.S. SUPREME COURT
AND OVERTHROW THE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT.
IN OTHER WORDS, AN UNPRECEDENTED
DANGEROUS POWER GRAB.
IN OTHER NEWS, RADICAL DEMOCRATS
ARE FALSELY ACCUSING TRUMP OF
INCITING AN INTERACTION INSURREC
WE ALREADY KNOW THE OUTCOME.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE
ACQUITTED AND SO THEY WILL NOW
OFFICIALLY BE WASTING YOUR MONEY
AND YOUR TIME.
AND ENOUGH.
WE GET IT.
YOU HATE PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT’S ACTUALLY AMAZING, ISN’T IT,
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
DONALD TRUMP HAS THIS UNIQUE
ABILITY TO LIVE IN THESE
PEOPLE’S MINDS EVERY SECOND,
MINUTE, HOUR OF EVERY DAY HE
LIVES THERE FOR YEARS AND HE IS
NOT AN OFFICE AND HE STILL LIVES
THERE.
AND NOW TODAY, SOME IN D.C. ARE
FIGURING OUT THAT THEY LOST IN
TERMS OF A CONVICTION.
WE WILL GET HIM THIS WAY.
NOW, REPUBLICANS, WE FOR ONCE
GET A BACKBONE.
WILL YOU FOR ONCE NOT
CAPITULATE, NOT GET IN?
HE IS IN OFFICE.
ENOUGH.
STOP WASTING OUR TIME AND OUR
MONEY.
AND IF THEY ARE GOING TO DO
THAT, THEN DO IT TO CHUCK AND DO
IT TO JOE.
AND DO IT TO KAMALA HARRIS AND
DO IT TO MAXINE WATERS.
I’M GOING TO TAKE TRUMP OUT
TONIGHT AND THEN YOU CAN DO IT
TO EVERYBODY ELSE THAT HAS SAID
INSIGHTFUL INSURRECTION-LIKE
LANGUAGE.
STOP LEGITIMIZING YOU
REPUBLICANS, YOU WEAK ONES, THIS
PSYCHOTIC RAGE.
FOCUS ON YOUR JOB.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC.
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
OUT OF WORK.
DEMOCRATS ONCE AGAIN PROVING MY
POINT.
THEY DON’T HAVE COMPASSION.
THERE IS NO AWARENESS.
THERE IS NO EMPATHY AND SADLY
HARDWORKING AMERICANS, AS WE
UNFORTUNATELY PREDICTED RIGHTLY,
ARE NOW PAYING THE PRICE.
JOBS ARE LOST.